hello I'm Zainab Badawi and welcome to
the Emanuel Center in London for this
intelligent square debate on artificial
intelligence and the threat it poses to
our jobs how much of a threat it poses
to our jobs now experts predict that
millions and millions of jobs could be
taken over by a computer or a robot in
the next 20 years and the question is
how worried should we be could this lead
to mass unemployment greater
inequalities even social unrest or
should we look forward to the day when
computers or robots can match or even
outperform humans so our motion today is
be afraid be very afraid
the robots are coming and they would
destroy our livelihoods and we have a
great panel arguing for and against the
motion
so Andrew keen is a internet
entrepreneur author and global
commentator on all things digital and
also arguing for the motion George
Magnus independent economists and
commentator who served as chief
economist of UBS the bank against the
motion water Isaacson best known for his
acclaimed biography of Steve Jobs and
pip amalgam is co-founder of H robotics
which makes drones for commercial
purposes that is our panel welcome to
you all
you're going to hear from our four
panelists make their opening arguments
and then I will throw the debate open to
the audience as you were all coming into
the hall today you were asked to vote on
the motion to see where you stand and
then we're going to ask you to vote
again at the end of the debate to see if
opinions have shifted so let's have our
first speaker arguing for the motion
Andrew keen executive director of the
Silicon Valley salon futurecast Andrews
been described as the Antichrist of
Silicon Valley and in his latest book
the Internet is not the answer
he argues that the Internet is having a
disastrous impact on our lives please
make your way to direction
so I got some good and bad news and
since we're in England we'll start with
the good news because we always need to
end with the bad news the good news from
your point of view and of course I'm
arguing that we should be scared but
there's one thing we shouldn't be scared
of we don't need to fear that in 20 or
30 or even 50 years we will become as
human beings indistinguishable from
computers in other words in 50 years we
could all be here it could be like a
science fiction movie and we won't know
whether you're sitting next to a
computer or not so that's the good news
you don't have to worry about
singularity but that doesn't mean we
should not be fearful of robot that
doesn't mean that we have a lot to be
scared about just because we're not
about to become indistinguishable from
robots doesn't mean they're about to
take away our livelihood and I'm
guessing that many of you are lawyers or
doctors journalists people trained in a
field you probably went to university
you spent years acquiring your
intelligence your skill your intellect
and you sell that skill as a teacher as
a doctor as an accountant as a lawyer
your value in the economy is based on
that expertise and it is you I'm afraid
who have the most to fear from this
great revolution the digital revolution
which one set of economies call our
second Machine Age because this is as
profound as earth-shaking
as culturally socially and above all
else economically profound as the first
Industrial Revolution of the 19th
century what we're on the brink of is a
world of increasingly intense
sophisticated artificial intelligence in
Silicon Valley where I'm from we call it
the machine learning revolution it's the
revolution of algorithms not the
traditional science fiction
old-fashioned HG Wells notion Doctor Who
of the robe
but trundling along the street the Dalek
get that image out of your mind think of
the algorithm think of the self-driving
car think of Google think of these
incredible new technologies which are
coming out of Silicon Valley which are
essentially replacing human labor
skilled human labor because here's the
paradox it's really hard for computers
to replicate what seems to us to be
simple tasks simple tasks like doing the
garden the washing up cooking cutting
someone's hair but on the other hand and
here is the dark scary horrific element
to the new world we're about to enter
it's not difficult to do what seems to
us at least to be the difficult things
the bad news and this is really bad news
for most of you and especially for your
kids because they are trying to follow
in your footsteps is that this world is
about to be swept away by the digital
revolution machines will learn how to
diagnose diseases what does that say for
all doctors around the world we already
have software now that grades essays
what becomes of school teachers what
becomes of university teachers -
researchers at Oxford University have
argued that over the next 10 years 47%
of our jobs will become irrelevant and
those 47% I'm afraid for you guys are
your kind of jobs and it's not just
skilled labour it's not just the
professional class it's not just those
people who have been fortunate or
unfortunate enough to go to university
we have a large audience a television
audience from the developing world these
are people who are embracing education
who see it as a way out of poverty I'm
afraid the news is really troubling for
them because they missed the bus
development which was always taken for
granted
it no longer will happen and we have
these increasing inequalities in Silicon
Valley because all the wealth is going
to the platform companies all the wealth
is going to companies like Amazon and
Google and the other companies that have
harnessed this technology for their own
benefit what we're seeing is a hollowing
out of the middle class or hollowing out
of the kind of jobs that you guys have
depended on and a replacement by the
algorithm by the Machine and by a tiny
group of people who own and control that
machine that's the reason I'm afraid why
you should be afraid very afraid thank
you
thank you very much so our second
speaker is speaking against the motion
water Isaacson and water became famous
for his internationally acclaimed book
on the life of Steve Jobs and he gained
unprecedented access to Steve Jobs in
the last months of his life he's also
president and CEO of the Aspen Institute
in Washington and a former chairman and
CEO of CNN and the managing editor of
Time magazine how do you fit it all in
thank you for making the time for us
today your time starts when you get to
the lectern thank you
very much and they have good news for
you and good news the good news is you
don't have to be afraid and the other
piece of good news is there's no bad
news in this the future is really going
to be cool since my since my
distinguished opponent mr. Kean started
with the Industrial Revolution and said
that this new revolution would be as
disruptive as the Industrial Revolution
let me begin by reminding you that the
Industrial Revolution wasn't all that
bad and at the end of it we had more
jobs not fewer jobs technology can
indeed be disruptive it can disrupt
certain jobs as mr. keen has said but it
always has and I submit always will
produce more jobs because it produces
more wealth more personal income more
per capita wealth and thus more things
that we can make and by every succeeding
generation has had a new wave of worry
dire warnings that jobs are being
threatened but in each one of these
cases they turned out to be wrong I was
at Time magazine I went back to look 50
years ago 50 years ago to this date
almost Time magazine did a cover just
like this just like the line that we're
looking at it said the robots are coming
Automation will take your job it quoted
a rather famous economic historian
Robert Hall Brenner most of you heard of
him
he says the new technology is
threatening a whole new group of skills
sounded just like mr. keen he said the
calculating the remembering the
comparing the okaying skills the
preserve of the office worker will go
away and machines will invade society to
make that type of human labor redundant
well guess what it's been 50 years and
since then soon after he wrote that we
had the greatest leaps of technology you
can imagine the internet the personal
computer and the microprocessor all come
into play
but nobody has been rendered redundant
there's more jobs and more types of jobs
now than there were 50 years ago as Mark
Andreasen the person who invented the
web browser said just as most of us
today have jobs that weren't invented a
hundred years ago the same will be true
a hundred years from now let me give
some examples there's the app economy it
began in 2008 when Steve Jobs was
convinced by other members of his
management team to allow outsiders to
create apps for the iPhone and then the
iPad the App Store alone since then has
created 627 thousand jobs the app
economy last year was a hundred billion
dollars far surpassing the film industry
this is an industry that did not exist
seven years ago other advances in
technology have helped facilitate new
forms of work such as a sharing economy
where people both here
New York New Orleans can drive cars be
part of Oberer be part of Airbnb be part
of lyft
likewise online marketplaces such as
Amazon and eBay have enabled the rise of
artisans makers the type of people that
existed in the pre-industrial age people
who had creative instincts and then
could have connections to customers
around the world if if you create a book
or a song now you have new ways to
publish as PIPA did with her own book
new ways to distribute if you dream up a
new specialty this world allows you to
find customers and provide a service
just as if you were an artisan or
service maker in the pre-industrial
revolution it even helps long establish
companies find markets all over the
globe there's a more fundamental shift
going on the economy that's also good
we're creating an on-demand or on tap
economy if you need a housekeeper or a
handyman you don't have to go to a
particular firm to get it it can be done
on tap if new technologies reduce the
total number of job
we'd all be out of work now and I doubt
that mr. King nor I nor you can guess
what wondrous jobs technology will bring
to our great grandchildren thank you
thank you very much indeed water our
second speaker for the motion is
economist George a Magnus after a long
career in finance in the City of London
George's has turned to writing and he's
written the age of aging a study of how
demographics are changing the world
economy and social systems so George
please make your way to the lectern and
tell us what you think
thank you very much so we're going to
talk economics now okay not populism so
and what I'd like to put you this
evening is that these digital and
robotic technologies constitute a very
powerful economic threat to our
livelihoods because of its effect on
jobs on income distribution and because
they demand that we focus on coping
mechanisms that we do not yet have now
our opponents in this debate and you've
already heard the first will try to
convince you that because mankind is
always adapted to new technologies
historically we shouldn't fear the
robotic revolution but this time as they
say it really is different and I'm going
to tell you why so just over 200 years
ago 64 men went on trial in York
these Luddites they went on a rampage
they burned mills and machinery and so
on but their campaign as we know was
myopic because the Industrial Revolution
or the first Industrial Revolution did
leave us all better off what we did is
we harnessed power and that exposed the
limits of human brawn but it was also
complementary to human endeavor this is
the key point it allowed us to blend men
and machines in ways which boosted
employment growth income and sustained a
rising and prosperous middle class the
modern technological revolution is
different it's exposing the limits not
of human brawn but of human brain and
instead of being complimentary modern
technology is displacing us capital is
being substituted more and more for
labor threatening jobs living standards
and as we know from contemporary
political debate the fabric of the
middle class not all jobs of course are
at risk as you've already heard machines
are not sufficiently dexterous to do all
kinds of manual work and lots of human
cognitive and judgmental skills have not
been replicated by machines and may not
but they've already been doing routine
based or
rule based jobs on the factory floor and
in offices for some time since 2010 the
number of low-paying and high-paying
jobs has gone up but the number of
middle level jobs middle wage paying
jobs has stagnated or dropped in a
pattern that is replicated across the
whole of Europe in the United States and
indeed in some emerging countries
notably in China and India successful
capitalism needs us to be fully engaged
not just as gadget savoring consumers
which we all are but also as producers
in other words we need to have stable
productive high levels of employment
which is what robotics is undermining
and because capitalism rewards scarcity
and because the robotics revolution is
generating productivity gains that are
benefiting a limited number of people
the principle rewards of modern
technology are accruing to the owners of
capital not the owners of labour in the
main think about the three biggest firms
in Silicon Valley they have 137 thousand
people and these three companies have a
market capitalization other words
they're worth 1.2 trillion dollars now
just cast your mind back 25 years to
1990 the three biggest companies in
Detroit had 10 times as many workers 1.2
million and their combined market value
was a mere 36 billion dollars this
fundamental change in the relationship
between capital and labor is also
illustrated by what we see in lots of
surveys about the rising share of
profits in national income and the
declining share of wages because as
economic inequality Rises so political
inequality Rises and those that benefit
from more political power obviously seek
changes which further their own economic
advantage and you could easily end up
without coping mechanisms at a very kind
of dystopian political future I would
remind you of the quip from Lord Keynes
the famous British economist who quipped
that in the long run we're all dead by
which he meant that the economists focus
on the long-run
equilibrium was a waste of time because
economic circumstances affect us now
next year in the next few years not at
some vague point in the unmeasurable
future and that's really what is
important and brings me to my final
point which is that we need to think
about this really seriously and try to
develop coping mechanisms there could be
many better education better training
improved access to capital job
protection schemes for certain
occupations higher minimum wage direct
transfers labor intensive construction
taxation of capital to help displaced
workers and so on I'm not commending
ladies and gentlemen any particular
coping mechanism to you tonight merely
pointing out that we have few and need
many as the robotics revolution evolves
thank you very much indeed Georg Magnus
well another economist now speaking
against the motion PIPA ma'am
bream well as well as creating flying
robots she runs the D rpm group which
advises institutional investors on
politics and policy and she was also an
advisor on financial markets to
president george w bush so please make
your way to the lectern because the
floor is yours now Pippa thank you
so the Buddhists say that suffering
comes from having an argument with
reality this is reality we can talk
about how artificial intelligence
robotics is going to change our lives
but the danger is that we confuse the
fact that the world economy makes these
relentless demands for change and that
is universal that is no change to the
past whatsoever as an economist I can
see that the demand for change on us is
deeply painful but what technology does
is empowers us to adapt and to take
advantage of our ability to engage in
new forms of economic activity and that
is why this reality is so very very
important I think the bottom line is
that we have to understand we've just
had roughly a hundred years of fast
advancing technological change we've had
30 years of a software revolution we now
have as much power in an iPad as used to
be only in a defense lab that is now at
everyone's fingertips and with that we
now commence a hardware revolution
physical items this is all part of what
new technology empowers us to do I take
you to the case of Jenny Doan who runs a
fantastic quilting company
in Missouri this is a woman who is
getting 30 million YouTube hits for
showing people how to make quilts a very
old-fashioned activity but not possible
without computers without the artificial
intelligence to make the pieces the
right size to sew them together quickly
she employs 85 people 300 people a day
come from around the world to go to her
shop in the middle of Missouri as
someone who's in the robotics industry I
can tell you most of the innovation
that's occurring in this field is not
coming from the big companies it's
coming from the hobbyist
it's coming from people who are just
playing with these things because they
can they have the power to and it's
interesting and it's fun when you even
listen to the senior management at
places like Apple they will say most of
our innovation is coming from small
groups of a few people principally
working out of a garage somewhere this
is a hugely democratic movement that is
beginning to permit people to enter into
the cutting edge of what's happening in
the world economy without having to have
elite skills to that end I have to say
as someone who's actually employing
people on this business what there's a
shortage of out there is not
intellectual capability or high levels
of education and training there's a
shortage of people who have the
practical skills who know how to make an
engine work who know how to do
electrical wiring I mean there are a lot
of educated idiots and I may be one of
them because I have lots of degrees but
I can't change the tap washer when it
goes wrong we need more people who can
do these things because they're the ones
who can be technology and powers to do
something robotics and artificial
intelligence won't destroy jobs they are
the tools by which we will build the
jobs we're going to have tomorrow and
they'll be different than the ones we do
today and thank goodness because that
will be much more in
interesting exciting and draw on our
capabilities much more than anything
else we can imagine and with that I'll
finish
thank you very much indeed Pippo Mangrum
so we're going to go to the audience in
the moment but first of all let me bring
you the pre debate vote how you the
audience here in London at the Emmanuel
Center voted on our motion today in this
intelligence squared debate the robots
are coming and they would destroy our
livelihood of course we are talking
about robotic and digital technology in
general not just the robots this is how
the audience here voted for the motion
thirty one percent against the motion
forty two percent and the don't knows
are twenty seven percent so I would say
panel that it is quite finely balanced
and we'll have to see how the audience
votes at the end of our debate so now
let me see who wants to make an
intervention or put a question from the
floor and briefly if you would also
who's got the microphone go ahead as a
technological optimist I was a little
bit disappointed with the arguments
against today here the advent of strong
artificial intelligence which could be
real human level intelligence has the
potential to actually completely replace
what humans are doing yo not just
enhance it and it seemed that that that
argument was completely lost and ignored
and actually you I ended up agreeing
with George that we need to accept that
and think about how that will
fundamentally change the world and
change society and not just ignore that
fact so you've moved from being a
technological optimist
are you now a technological pessimist
I'm still an optimist obviously we have
to think about it
like if we don't wish to depress you and
bring me down at all okay any other dude
do please yell hey one conclusion I make
from the from the title is regardless of
whether to be afraid or not afraid I
think there is consensus that it's
coming so the change is coming and
nobody's can stop it the question I'm
posing to all panelists is how do we
mitigate the challenges coming from the
robots coming in so far that has not
been addressed perhaps we can address it
thank you and maybe Andrew keen do you
want to look at that I mean I sort of it
suppose that brings us to regulation or
how governments should respond to a need
legislation that's point there what we
need to remember about the Industrial
Revolution that when that happened when
you had child labor when you had
terrible pollution when you had the
uncontrolled consequences of the early
Industrial Revolution the market didn't
resolve things it was the government
that had to step in the grownups and if
we leave it to the children to the
Zuckerberg zand the teals of this world
then I fear that the thing will get even
worse the problem is also with
politicians they're too slow there are
two speeds in the world today there's
the hyper speed of Silicon Valley and
there's the hyper slowness of political
bodies in Washington DC
so we can't necessarily slow Silicon
Valley down but we can certainly speed
up the traditional political authorities
people you want to respond to Andrew
yeah I would take exactly up the
opposite side of that and say what we
want to do is speed up the integration
of humanity into technology we want to
bring people into this space faster
there's a global shortage right now for
example of welders they're hiring people
in their 70s to work with modern
robotics because welding still is a
skill a robot can't replicate what a
human knows about this the human nuance
and knowledge of how things work is
still essential in the application of
robotics what does your site say in some
regions of the world stand to benefit
more than others surely well but this is
the normal case of the world economy
it's a fluid moving thing and we should
stop thinking about national boundaries
we should think more about on a global
basis where do we see economic activity
occurring and I think the more dispersed
it is the better that's a very kind of
romantic view where which I would
applaud as well but I just don't think
it's right
sorry I'll give you a classic case right
I mean we all you know we all wonder at
them you know at China and it's
magnificent achievements over the last
25 years but I think China was unique
right
India wants to basically build up
India's manufacturing base based on
essentially around low value products
you know over the next 25 years to
become a China
it's just not going to happen because
the technology is going to pass them by
they need to find new solutions to the
problems they've got Andrew briefly I
just want to come back at what purpose
say because I think she should cross
side she's making our argument for us
she's not mentioning lawyers or doctors
or accountants or teachers all we hear
from her is welders robots aren't able
to become welders big deal there isn't
enough jobs out there for everyone to
become welders or plumbers the problem
is the profound skilled labor that
represented the backbone of our
meritocratic middle-class economy and
from these guys that all I hear are
entrepreneurs
I hear app developers I hear welders I
don't hear the dignity of labour that
represented in core of 20th century
lives so here's the question to the
audience
would you rather have your surgeon have
more precision if you would rather have
a surgeon that has more precision then
you are in favor of the human element
guiding the technology you are in favor
of a world in which the human being
still has an essential role to play but
the technology makes what we do better
I didn't think that we've always thought
that a I was coming ever since about
1956 and it always is a little bit
harder than we think so whether it is
domain awareness or our creativity the
humans have a way of cognitive thinking
that is so fundamentally different in
its carbon-based wetware system of our
brain then in the digital silicon system
that artificial intelligence remains a
mirage and it's not about to change
everything our creativity our humanism
will always be part of the party all
right okay let's take some more points
from the floor got a microphone yeah it
against the motion at the start but I
have to say that those speaking against
it have engaged in a whitewash I'd like
to ask them what do they think robots
will not be able to do in 30 years time
okay thanks we take another one there
was a chap in the red yup I think the
party against is saying that we'd have
to worry because we just need to have
faith in human creativity so I put it to
the panel how about a shed for every man
in England at what
yeah uh-huh I've got five school boys
here aged between 10 and 13 the next
generation we'd like to know if each
member of the panel would recommend a
job for them to do
if you could stand I had a question
actually with maybe the exception of
pepper how many of the panelists have
actually walked the floors of a robotics
laboratory because if you do I mean you
take a company like toy talk based in
Silicon Valley they hire everyone from
Pixar writers to animation experts to
engineers to marketing people I mean
it's a very diverse cross-disciplinary
function the likes of which we've not
seen in technology and what's your view
of that right let's take some of those
then I think we can collapse the five
school boys what kind of jobs they might
do with that question about what robots
can't do in in 30 years and we want to
be able to make the answer in a way if
you're going to be looking for a job as
you know a fifth grade or whatever be
creative the car what will computers
robots not do that we can do they work
by algorithm almost by definition they
are not creative they don't think out of
the box they don't think imaginatively
our minds are cognitive so we supply
intelligence squared debate errs no
robot is going to replace this panel but
nor will it replace the Pixar people and
the animation people and the people
doing the creativity and if you learn to
code and connect the arts to the
sciences that was Steve Jobs great
advice the welders and the plumbers are
creative creative but I would say take
the shed that the guy in the back
recommended give it to the five boys
give them an iPad and the technology
that they need and then let them learn a
lot of different things because you
aren't going to have one job you're
gonna have many jobs you aren't gonna
have one career you're gonna have many
careers that is what technology allows
the bottom line though to answer your
question as well madam is that the kinds
of things that technology companies are
doing actually employ very very few
people it's what do you do with the
people in Bradford or in the slums of
Mumbai and so on and so forth those are
the people that are really going to
suffer from that it's a great question
about kids what they shouldn't shouldn't
do I don't know what to tell you to do
but I can give you two pieces of advice
about what not to do so the first is
don't become a welder
the second and and this is even more
serious than not becoming a welder don't
get a shed and don't listen to PIPA
about this idea that somehow we should
all go into sheds and innovate and
become the next entrepreneur we only
hear about the Zuckerberg zand the jobs
of Silicon Valley but for every
Zuckerberg there hundreds of thousands
of failures so we cannot encourage
everyone to go into their shed and
become entrepreneurs that's the ultimate
seduction and I think we will regret it
more questions
lady here with the scarf if you could
stand please
mr. eilerson you referred to musicians
being able to make music in all these
ways well yes they can use their iphones
and record a track but they can't pay a
mortgage they can't feed their children
on the money they're going to get back
from it that's the first point and the
second is institutions and projects in
the media that encouraged us to tweet to
Facebook to use social media to promote
what they're doing but none of us are
getting paid for that and there seems to
be more and more and more of expecting
the general population to do an awful
lot for absolutely nothing and we have
to buy the kit to do it with thank you I
know that something Andrews written
about yes gentleman there if you could
stand I had some life-saving surgery
before Christmas and it did involve a
lot of animatronics and laser work but I
tell you the next morning my morphine
induced super I would not have wanted a
robot to come into my room and tell me I
was going to live okay thank you and
seems to me that there is a deeper
underlying question here that nor if you
have really addressed which is what kind
of society we want that what work is for
in the first place there's because some
people also talk about moving to a
person right well you know we can be
more efficient because all these tools
and we can maybe just have it to day
work week instead nothing more like
social it's Kodokan would you like that
what do you do
today me I've been Mike Smith that's why
I'm the bit
don't they work in Denmark or something
I'm sure they do very hard okay well who
wants to take that what is work for I
mean you're talking about preserving
jobs I'll take the Danish gentleman's
question yeah it's interesting think you
know in 1930 ish Lord Keynes actually
wrote a little pamphlet called the
economic consequences for our
grandchildren and he looked forward a
hundred years and actually he imagined a
period when productivity of the people
that were employed was so high that
actually it was able to support
everybody in or pretty much everybody in
a in a life of just considerably
expanded leisure but you're right you
know there may be a point in the future
when when that will be true but it can't
see it happening
yeah the gentleman from from Denmark
said I'm said why do you want to work
the answer is obvious to earn a living
to be paid to pay your mortgage to feed
your children it's how we make sure that
our children have good lives
all right so without jobs things are
pretty bad we'll just end up in sheds Oh
there was a point on that point about
the chat we had the life-saving surgery
and said he would not have wanted to
woken up the next morning with a robot
telling him that the operation had gone
well I mean that's the point of what are
humans good for in the future and it's
things like interpersonal skills which
George is mentioned the type of
understanding of nuances and creativity
that come from being able to understand
a patient or being legal client or
whatever the type of things that
machines have never done and we see no
evidence that they would do better sure
and emotional intelligence that the
empathy gene is not something that
machines robots created in a digital
on-off manner we have never seen it
happen I know people kind of great
robots that smile at you yeah nobody has
ever wanted one of those to wake up in
the morning once they've had an
operation we're on the nation of human
strengths cognitive strengths combined
with the tools of technology will always
outstrip robots working alone or humans
working alone and what we have seen
throughout the digital revolution is
that there are certain things that
humans are really good at and certain
things machines are good at and when you
can make that partnership that's when
you have the great leaps but it always
provides a role whether it's for the
lawyer or the doctor or the artist or
the musician to do something that that
can't be done better by a machine
working alone really then we'll go back
to the floor look at some of the
greatest innovations of our time if we
look at the MIT Media Lab where they're
doing extraordinary work in all these
areas we're now able to grow food in a
container using no soil almost no water
very few chemicals virtually no
fertilizer and only a little bit of
light that's from the particular part of
the spectrum the plant needs you grow it
four to eight times faster than in real
life and you get higher nutritional
content and
higher taste now you cannot ask a
computer to create that human beings
create that computers can execute based
on algorithms once you've decided what
it is you need executed but to solve the
problems our society faces that still is
about human ingenuity all right let's
just take a couple more interventions
from the floor that yeah hello um my
question is for the speaker's really and
it is should this be a gendered debate
that is is the inevitable growth in
artificial intelligence going to help or
hinder a progression towards female
economic and social equality thank you
yeah I um I think this arguments getting
a little complex personally referring to
the lady talking about welding there is
a situation where we have human beings
as weldings or welders do you think
corporations if they could employ robots
which would be cheaper they would thank
you and yeah I think it's probably the
final one I can go to there yeah if you
could stand I'm just wondering we've
spoken a lot about sort of jobs like
teaching at law medicine
entrepreneurialism but I'm curious what
will happen to jobs like train drivers
bus drivers people at work in
supermarkets I mean even all the drivers
of uber will they need to exist in 30 50
years time yeah well we know that there
are plans for unmanned driverless cars
and uber looking at that too so I'll
just take that gentle no because he's
had his hand up for a long time so the
chap in the spectacles there yeah we've
heard that machines might usurp and
therefore are dangerous for machines
cannot be more intelligent they can just
compliment but what if there's a third
way and that our evolutionary roadmap
was meant to lead us to a place where we
create something that can evolve itself
can be far more intelligent and better
than us more competent more benevolent
and we should embrace this and look to
something far better than we are
I think that's turkeys voting for
Christmas there isn't it that final
point there thank you very much sober
huh you've uh just to develop that
question about women I mean a lot of the
world's menial jobs and back-breaking
work that a lot of African women farmers
do for instance I kind of think you know
is this how do you see the advancement
of technological jobs and skills good
guy I know Iqbal Kadir founded the first
mobile phone network in Bangladesh and
who did he go to to hand out the
physical phones the oldest woman in
every remote village in Bangladesh
because she was the power center in
those communities and he taught those
women how to use the phone so that the
local community could figure out how
much they get paid for their produce
when they took it into the big city this
is very empowering stuff this notion
that somehow everybody gets left behind
by technology it simply doesn't add up
in the data it doesn't show in our
investment strategies where we're all
investing in this all over the world it
does and you can't solve the world's
problems by anecdote it does you can
solve the world problem by technology
you cannot solve the wellstones well
surprise was once over that Tiffany that
is not an animal Jennifer had you say I
was going to address the lady who's
asked the question about human about
females earlier on but it just did what
it did remind me is that in the first
Industrial Revolution the only way that
you know we had to have a social
revolution as well as an industrial
revolution otherwise the whole thing
would have fallen apart and some of the
things that happened as a consequence of
the social revolution Andrew mentioned
one of them before which was the
abolition of child labor the
emancipation of women was also part of
that right that didn't happen women had
to agitate for that and eventually
governments had to legislate for it yet
but the question was is we how far would
robotic and digital technology empower
women all over the world to release them
from my view meeting which on its own it
will not be sufficient it will need the
intervention of institutions and
governments to make that happen properly
I think that yeah you won't have a right
to reply go ahead that's the key all of
us have to make a philosophical decision
does the answer lie in human effort or
does the answer lie in the state with
smart people up at the top I worked in
the White House I've been one of those
people they call those smart guys in
Washington I don't believe that the
state is better at determining what the
outcome ought to be than all of our
personal collective decisions but that's
the choice that you and the audience
have to make okay thank you
so I now have the results of the post
debate vote let me just remind you how
you voted audience when you came in to
the hall for the motion the robots are
coming and they would destroy our life
who is 31% for the motion 42% against
the motion 27% don't know after the
debate for the motion 43% against the
motion 52% and the don't know is 5% so
it seems to me that the for the motion
gained 12 percentage points and against
the motion gained 10 percentage points
so it's the in the audience it's the
against the motion the robots are coming
and destroy our livelihoods they're
obviously more sanguine about it so I
think in a sense both sides of one so
clearly
so clearly anyway there's been agreement
on the increasing impact that artificial
intelligence and robots will have on our
lives whether that's to the benefit or
to the detriment of mankind well I don't
think we have consensus on that thank
you to my panel thank you to my audience
here thank you to intelligence squared
for making this debate possible thank
you to you wherever you are watching
this from me Zainab Badawi at the
Emanuel Center in London goodbye